who from your dancing with the stars
competitors do you want to face in the
ring oh man are you kidding me
like let's go jojo let's go all day she
she beat me once on the dance floor but
jojo's ready
jojo can step up to the plate
and have to say jojo the couple i want
to save
is jojo and jenna i'm gonna have to save
jojo the word shocking keeps happening
every week this season but this wasn't
just shocking this was depressing
was it for you did you vote for me then
we love you so much what went through
your mind when you guys were standing
out there with jojo and jeff honestly i
was laughing when i saw amanda jojo i
even went to her i went oh my god you've
got to be kidding me well mike your face
your face was like
what realized that
i was like oh oh yeah and my favorite
part was the judges going this is a
tough decision jojo's had two perfect
scores are you kidding me yeah and we're
over here getting eights we're like um
yeah gee i wonder so you it felt like
writing on the wall was on the wall but
honestly like
as much as like i'm i don't have any ill
feelings like this is a competition i
put my best out there i had the best
choreographer she was creative she
helped me get to where i needed to be
and to be honest i felt like i did a
great job and like you know i i didn't
feel like i fell on my face i thought i
represented you know myself as well as
my family as well as everyone the best i
possibly could
[Music]
whitney this guy here every week he is a
joy to watch he lights up the screen his
family is beautiful he's amazing so what
happened how does that happen that you
two end up in the bottom too because
there was no part of me that thought
that was happening tonight i honestly
don't know i am shocked as well because
like you said mike is
the most hardworking person like i've
worked with honestly like he gives it
110 anything that he does and this
competition was no different he did
fantastic i'm so sad it got cut short
but you know what sometimes that just
happens
yeah i mean somebody has to get
eliminated well here's the thing mike i
know you're always so positive and so
driven but you're also so passionate we
can see and feel how much you care so
when you go home tonight
what is your emotional state what are
you reflecting on i gave my best both
mentally physically emotionally i give
everything i had and it wasn't enough
and that's fine
all my failures in life like all my
failures have taught me more than any of
my successes and i don't consider this a
failure i consider it maybe a minor
setback to where i learned a lot about
myself and that's what i take away from
this like it was like i felt like i was
doing this the entire time just trying
to like catch up catch up catch up and
to be honest like sometimes it's not
enough and that's fine
does that make any sense at all no i'm
soaking that in truly because i mean the
thing is and everybody keeps saying this
season like toughest competition in
terms of the talent that's here what's
the biggest thing you learned about
yourself
uh that no matter how much the
competition is like like that even when
you literally look at it and you look at
the paper and you go i really don't have
a chance i'm still gonna do my best like
i'm still going to like i look at the
competition and i'm not being like
whatever but it's like you're going up
against like jojo and amanda and you're
looking at them and they're incredible
they're getting tens perfect scores and
you're like how am i even going to
compete with these guys and then you go
out there and each every tuesday you're
like i'm not gonna get this dance and
then monday you're out there doing the
dance that she created to the best of
your ability and honestly like i felt
like i hit my steps a little stiff sure
but if you want to bring me in the club
i guarantee i won't be stiff at all like
i can do a body roll all day long you
you thrive on a body roll
that was the first move that we did in
our cha-cha
yes we see you just shine in a body roll
is it is there any level if you're being
honest is there any level of frustration
when you do consider the talent that
amanda or jojo had coming in and the
experience they had coming in everyone
has different like you can't you can't
be like oh this person is this
background this way i have a wwe
background i uh jimmy as a musician like
that that's what this is this is dancing
with the stars and stars call from all
walks of entertainment so it's your job
to if you are going up against someone
that may have a little bit more
experience to step up to the plate and
try to swing and hit it as hard as you
can so you get a home run i just hate
hearing you say it wasn't enough because
i don't feel like i wasn't and i don't
like that either and i don't think it
was a failure either just because you
got eliminated early just because you
didn't win the mirror ball is not a
failure like look at all the things that
you have accomplished
i didn't win the mirror ball that's it
you did a pasta dough blade you were
hell raiser you know what the worst part
about this is oh my gosh we have to stop
this interview like i even told her this
you want a therapy session so my dad
comes in right and says mike you're a
little stiff then the judges judge me
and they say you're a little stiff then
i get eliminated what do you think
is going to be the conversation with my
dad tonight i told you told you told
yourself steve if you listen to me mike
you would have done great
mike will be launching a therapy app
coming this fall you can wrestle your
emotions
it was awesome to see your dad your wife
has been such a part of this journey
have you talked to her since the news
what do you think she's going to say
yeah i've gotten many texts she was like
you were the best you're you're number
one in her heart
in her mind like i am the mirror ball
champion in our family so and that's all
that matters isn't it
we were wondering this we have watched
you i mean you were already so fit but
we can see a physical transformation in
you have you lost weight doing this 15
pounds yeah and now like i've already
got wwe calling me go can't wait to have
you on monday night raw and i'm like oh
my gosh i am not in ring shape right now
i have to gain weight like i need it
like i lost like i'm about 200 pounds
right now i'm trying to get a dancer
shape
you